Let's now think
about Type 2 regions.
And you'll see that they're
kind of very similar definitions
and it's really a
question of orientation.
Type 2 region is a
region-- I'll call it
R2-- that's the set of all
x, y's, and z's in three
dimensions such
that-- and now instead
of thinking of our domain
in terms of xy-coordinates,
we're going to think of them
in terms of yz coordinates,
such that our yz pairs are
a member of some domain.
I'll call it D2 since we're
talking about Type 2 regions.
And x is bounded below
by some function of yz.
So I'll call it g1 of yz is
less than or equal to x, which
is less than or equal to some
other function of yz, g2 of yz.
And so you'll immediately see
a very similar way of thinking
about it, but instead of
having z vary between two
functions of x and y as
we had in a Type 1 region,
we now have x varying between
two functions of y and z.
Now let's think about some
of the shapes we explored.
We saw that these
two right up here,
this sphere and the cylinder,
were Type 1 regions,
but this dumbbell, the way
that I oriented it here,
was not a Type 1 region.
Let's think about which of
these are Type 2 regions
and what might not
be a Type 2 region.
So first let's think
about the sphere.
So I have my axes
right over here.
Let me scroll down a little bit.
So I got my axes.
And so over here, our
domain, we could still
construct our sphere,
but our domain
is now going to be
in the yz plane.
So yz plane is this
business right over here.
So this will be our domain.
I want to make it more
spherical than that.
So our domain is this right
over here in the yz plane.
That is our D2.
And now the lower
bound, in order
to construct the solid region
of the sphere or the globe
or whatever you want to call
it, the lower bound on x
would be kind of the back half
of the sphere, the one that's
away from us right over here.
So the lower bound--
so let me see
how well I can wire
frame it at first.
I can do a better job than that.
So with my ghost do
something like that,
then do something like that.
But this is if the domain
right over here is transparent.
But all we might catch-- we'll
just catch a glimpse of it
in the back right over here.
So it's the side of the sphere
that's facing away from us.
And then the upper
bound on x would
be the side of the
sphere that's facing us.
So if I were to
do some contours,
it might look
something like this
and then look
something like this.
And then we would color in this
entire region right over here.
And x can take on all of the
values above that magenta
surface and below
this green surface.
And essentially,
it would fill up
the globe for every yz
point in our domain.
So a sphere is both a Type
1 and a Type 2 region.
Actually, we're
going to see it's
going to be a Type
3 region as well.
What about this cylinder
right over here?
Can we construct it or
think about it in a way
that it would actually
be a Type 2 region?
So let's try to do that.
So let me paste it.
So what if we had
a domain-- what
if our domain was
something like this?
It was a rectangle
in the yz plane.
So this is our domain, a
rectangle in the yz plane.
So that would be my D2.
And what if the
lower bound was kind
of the back side
of the cylinder?
So the backside of
the cylinder, try
to draw it as good as I can.
And so if we just saw
the outside of it,
it would look
something like that.
It's facing away from
us so we barely see it.
If we could see
through the cylinder
or see through the little
flat cut of the cylinder,
it would look
something like that.
So that over there
would be our g1.
And then our g2 would be the
front side of the cylinder.
The g2 could be the front
side of the cylinder.
So let me color it
in as best as I can.
So the g2 would be the
front side of cylinder.
And x can vary above
g1 and below g2,
and it would fill up
this entire cylinder.
So we see that this same
cylinder that we also saw
was a Type 1 region can
also be a Type 2 region.
Now what about this
hourglass thing that we saw
could not be a Type 1 region?
Can this be a Type 2 region?
Well, let's think about it.
I'll do it the same way.
We can construct a domain.
So maybe our domain,
it's in the y-- well,
it should be in the yz plane
if we're talking about Type 2
regions or if we want to think
of it as a Type 2 region.
So our domain could be this kind
of flat hourglass shape that's
in the yz plane.
So our domain could be a
region that looks something
like this in the yz plane.
So this is kind
of flattened out.
So this is our domain
right over there.
And then the lower
bound on x, g1,
could be a surface,
the function of y and z
that is kind of the
backside of our hourglass.
The backside of our
hourglass you could see.
I'll try to show the
contours from the underside
right over there.
So that could be our g1.
And then our g2 could be the
front side of the hourglass.
So my best attempt to draw the
And I could color it in.
And so the way I somewhat
confusingly drew it just now,
you see that this hourglass
oriented the way it is
would actually be
a Type 2 region.
Now if we were to rotate
it like this-- so let
me draw it like this.
Edit.
So if we were to
make it like this so
that the top of my
hourglass is facing
us-- try my best to draw it.
So let's say the top intersects
the x-axis right over there.
This is the bottom of my
hourglass right over there.
And then it bends in and then
comes back out like that.
For the same reasons that
this was not a Type 1 region,
this now would not
be a Type 2 region.
For any zy, you can see there
could be multiple x points that
are associated with
the different points
of this hourglass.
You can't just have a
simple lower and upper round
functions right over here.
So this right over here
is not a Type 2 region.
You could show a
rationale or this
is going to be a Type 1 region.
You could create a region
over here in the xy plane
and have an upper and lower
bound functions for z.
So you could be Type 1, but
this will not be Type 2.